Ngày mừng tâm tâm tâm mọi bộ ngoài sông ai đã xa tuyên bố chỉ chích vệnh lực miệng bắt sử một tâu trở rau châu cường ai
lại bắt đặt thế dân. Cái đây là hành động có thể giảm tối lao hàng thang thang của sự chính trị trong khu vực.
Mắt sức bắt trở săng động thái này là mạc thấp vướng sự dụng bố lực đồ việc có hạt động hàng hài dân sự.
Theo phía ngạc con tò bị bắt sử được cấp phép trâu cường ai từ tháng 12 và việc Mỹ đây soạn chưa to ở thủ đoàn là không thể chấp nhận.
Mắt sức bắt thẳng định các biển pháp trường phát đơn phương của Mỹ và phương tay là mất thử pháp.
Về phí Mỹ, bố tương lãnh cho ông cho biết tò bè là một biber sử dụng sau vì phạm các lãnh trường phát.
Lên quan đến hoạt động vận chuyển dầu mỏ của Vin Diesel,
hồi chính tình nhận mạnh các biển pháp này nhằm bảo vệ lợi íc ăn linh của gia.
Nha chẳng hiện từ chối phản hồi chiếc tuyên bố của Mắt sức bắt.
Dới chuyên gia chơi rằng vụ việc có thể làm ra thang thang thang thang chung quanh hiện ngạ Mỹ bố đã phức tạm.